this breaking news in the last minute or
two the government it seems then going
against what the jcvi who advised
ministers on vaccines what they had to
say
yeah they decided not to make a decision
instead
pass past that uh decision-making
process on to professor chris whittie
who's england's chief medical officer as
well as the cmos of the other nations of
the uk they have
now agreed to go ahead with vaccinations
of 12 to 15 year olds it is although
just an offer this is not of course not
mandatory as with the rest of the
population kids are not going to be
forced to
take this vaccine it will be
doses of the pfizer vaccine that will be
offered to young people the rollout will
happen as soon as possible we're told
and it will happen through
the government hope the school
vaccination program but we should also
point out the cmos have uh suggested
this it's still up to the government to
accept it or not of course we think it's
highly likely they will
accept it and this comes
at a time when we're expecting a lot of
announcements about uh covid 19. there's
going to be an update soon possibly
today possibly tomorrow about the uk
booster program that's a third dose uh
for some people we know that those who
are immunocompromised a half a million
people in the country will already uh
get a third dose but who else and uh
when we certainly think if it does
happen it's likely that those who are
older and vulnerable uh will be first in
line or near the front of the queue then
tomorrow we've got this big press
conference with boris johnson alongside
him in downing street will be
uh chris which medical officer and
patrick valance uh the chief scientific
advisor those three uh senior figures
joining together
in
in an event that may not be actually
announcing a lot of new decisions by the
prime minister but instead almost sort
of bringing all these different uh
moments together that are going to come
this week almost repackaging them into
i think an attempt to communicate all
these complicated things are happening
all in one
to the public it's important because we
are heading towards the winter months
and indeed this will be boris johnson's
winter covid plan that is important
because we all always know that the nhs
is under greater pressure in the winter
months there is some evidence to suggest
that viruses like cover 19 do survive
longer in cold weather conditions and of
course we're not going to be outside or
in highly ventilated areas in the winter
months we're likely to be
inside in rooms without the windows open
because it is cold outside and therefore
strontium will i think set out the
mitigating factors he could introduce if
infection rates were to rise don't think
it's going to be more lockdowns the uh
steer we're getting from number 10 and
others in government is that boris
johnson of course wants to avoid that at
all costs more this would be him pulling
levers like reintroducing mass guidance
or reintroducing work from home guidance
but only of course if necessary
yesterday the house secretary said that
plan for
vaccine passports in nightclub and large
events in england do start at the end of
this month would be scrapped but
remember sanji javid and boris johnson
has reflected this today
have stressed we could introduce vaccine
passports if we really need to nothing
is uh ruled out but as you say jonathan
the main headline this hour is going to
be that announcement that vaccines are
now being offered to 12 to 15 year olds
in the uk across the uk not just england
but scotland wales and northern ireland
too and the roll out the government
hopes will start as soon as possible
okay joe so we'll get all the
nitty-gritty tomorrow as you say uh
boris johnson not ruling out a further
lockdown if it really was necessary uh
what have labour had to say about all of
this
uh well they haven't reacted to all of
this yet but kiyosama was speaking
earlier this is just a sense of what his
view of the whole issue is
we need regularly testing we need to
take what steps we can whether that's
masks where it's appropriate or
ventilation in schools we don't want
to go back into another lockdown we will
wait and see what the government has to
say
tomorrow
and obviously if we support it we will
say we support it
because you know across the piece i
think people want to come out of the
restrictions but not go back into a
lockdown
now there may be a new reaction from
zakir sharma to this announcement and
indeed i'm sure we'll have a reaction to
the announcement tomorrow boris johnson
is going to be making but if we look
back to the pandemic labour are
generally actually pretty supportive of
the health measures when they criticize
the government it's often about the way
they've gone about it and the
communications and decision-making
around it as i say boris johnson making
a significant intervention tomorrow at
press conference expected in downing
street in the afternoon or perhaps in
the early evening alongside chris
whittie and the patrick bounce